[Musica]
la sentite la sentite questa musica
sapete che sono e questo questo è il
suono dei vostri neuroni che stanno
bruciando perché ve lo faccio vedere io
signore e signori oggi siamo su io sono
pesce ayane fish è un gioco creato dagli
stessi creatori di ayane brad e disagi
al simboletto la borsa studiosi che
quindi mi hanno fatto campare per anni
che vedo che ci sono un sacco di livelli
facciamoli io sono pesce l'ex co credo
swing towards the light quindi devo
andare
ok ha quindi io sono un pesce vero che
io penso visto per comandare una boccia
forse mi sono sbagliato io ma io posso
anche uscire tipo del tino va bene si
posso farlo che strano che è bello mi
sento di nuovo pieno di paul eccoci mi
sembrava dice ok allora io sono un
pescina una boccia ok però la boccia non
si apre io il mio obiettivo è quello di
arrivare nel mare quindi io devo uscire
di qua e raggiungere l'oceano per essere
libero per essere un pesce free tipo
nemo questo è un altro check point che
si no
fa niente avrò un'altra vita c'è creano
posso ancora vivo ma muoiono parte muoio
un viaggio che tristezza sono morta
europee il volto perché perché se stavi
cercando la via per cercare la libertà
va bene è bellissimo riproviamo però non
me lo fa fare all'inizio c'è poi eccolo
bene ok è difficile perché si gira la
bozza c'è tu devi tentare di girarla a
posto escono bene bene ci siamo ok a
fermo
madonna guarda chi ci sta con le pinne
facilmente
e allora vai vai di qua a sinistra bravo
a sinistra bra bravo
ora devi devi uscire di sci e sci
l'oceano e laggiù dove dio c'erano e la
voce anno bravo ma la via votiamo
come ti amo no no no no perfetto
non so questo sono un fenomeno la gente
voleva che io giocassi a fort nei due
non ho mai scelto quella strada la
strada dell'oscurità
ho sempre scelto la strada più difficile
quella di giocare ai giochi very very e
difficili come questo e guarda dove mi
ha portato sono un fenomeno sono fermati
devo andare di qua si no sì verso il
cavo bravo
mamma mia se ci riprovo mille volte non
ci riesco a va benissimo benissimo
ragazzi occhio
ora devo prendere stavi a occhio occhi
occhio anche occhio piano piano piano
piano piano
no vabbè ci abbiamo provato
meno male che se gli accese natiche e
non a milano zio seno era un casino
trovare il mare dico ora non ti far
investire ci sono le macchine non le
macchine tu non le devo andare
bravo bravo le occhio le macchie ho
chiamato io nella mia vita ho sfiga ma
tanta ma proprio verso le macchine non
le devi non le devi considerare bravo
bravissimo bravissimo vai mayes bird
mamma mia che come ti amo
come ti amo bravo sul marciapiede orafe
frena frena no basta basta perfetto è il
muro quindi ora devi andare sul molo
perché qua non scavalchi 6 a un passo
dalla vittoria la vedo non vedo già sta
alla stalla guardalo
c'è un modo perfetto per chi si vuole
buttare in mare e tu sei quello che lo
vuole fare
quindi perfetto ci sono poi una domanda
che voglio farmi che c'è qualcuno mi
spiega cos'è successo perché non ho
capito la domanda che mi stavo per fare
proprio questa ma se io mi butto in mare
adesso come nuoce sono ancora nella
boccia quindi praticamente dovrei
rompere la boccia adesso rompi la boccia
rompi lancio anche persone ancora nella
boccia la rotta e 57 minuti 34 va beh
cambiamo mappa con la musica che finisce
nel modo giusto per farci sia un haga
nuova giornata per entrare nel male sono
sempre io comunque ci siamo ragazzi
siamo
eccolo non è vero e veramente difficile
sto gioco ragazzo cavalca potevi c'entra
della scala zio o bravissimo perfetto
allora dov'è che si trova socieà non lo
posso raggiungere praticamente luciano
impossibile è completamente in un altro
punto del mondo va bene non va bene devo
salire sul capito a perché prima si
scheggia cui si rompe ok che lo trovare
il modo di scendere senza farmi male
come face book e ne so immagino che io
debba scendere in un punto un po più
avanti tipo questo
non è così ah no a noi c'è il tutto il
tetto di là che posso fare io volevo
sbrigare mela invece no ok no no non
dico di ragya bravo gira gira di più
gira di più bravo bravissimo ora non
cadere non cadere qua non cadere con
bravissimo bravo di rendere su quel
check point di bellissimo bravo zio mode
on stage i miti faccio che ha posto a
porta posto beh ora devo scendere
non so come ma devo scendere verso il
trampolino quindi non qua un po più
avanti
va bene se scendi con le volte devi
centrare trappolino e vabbè succedono
cose sono arrivato nell'oceano non è
vero ma sono vivo sono in piscina per
chrome è effettivamente la piscina non
mi fa male perché una piscina ok quindi
entro nel tubo 6 dove scarica in piscina
questo scarica nell'oceano ragazzi
attenzione ci siamo bellissimo no nelle
fogne valore sono nelle fogne ma dai
quindi non devo passare sopra la città
ma sotto che tattica va bene come faccio
devo fare un salto dal basso verso
l'alto che esalta e non salta bellissimo
l'aria ma da che il plot twist
incredibile aspettava di su perfetto
bravo madonna incredibile ragazzi sono
massa ha visto gioco quand'è che fanno
le finali tour mondiale partecipo io ve
lo assicuro perfetto altro che ninja
veli no no la plastica la plastica
maledetto sto mondo che non e plastic
free ma edizione per la prima volta
capisco bene cosa prova un animale
porca vacca se buttate la plastica nelle
spiagge e vengo limiti non malrovescio
riguarda non inquinata
fate la differenziata per l'amor di dio
ditelo ai vostri genitori fatte da tutti
chi butta la plastica male è da buttare
lui
mamma mia ragazzi questi sì che ne sanno
comunque sono arrivato al check point
teoricamente ci dovremmo essere perfetto
no di centrare il buco bravo zio devi
c'entra bravissimo
quanto manca al mare ci siamo vedo
l'oceano
lo sento ma no dove sono
ma dai facciamo così che una bellissima
ovunque checkpoint va bene va bene
[Musica]
allora tu vedi un pesce che muove le
cose e la tua reazione e questa
aggiungere oceano non dovrebbe essere
troppo difficile se questo non ho cosa
vuoi no no umano schifoso mezzo incastra
una vera che pezzente
ma proprio gli esseri umani devono
scomparire dalla faccia del pianeta
volume essere inferiori stupidi ma pare
che pezzenti che ci sono risorse non vi
può raggiungere non mi può raggiungere
non può raggiungerli sono più se io però
nuota nuota zio nota guarda ruota veloce
90 veloce è una gara incredibile
ehi ehi ehi ehi lo dice tua sorella ha
capito ai anno non è vero c'è nelle
pietre le pietre mi interrompono la
corsa
se questa può essere definita corsa non
possono che guardare dietro e sono non
mi concentro no bravo zio bravo zaia non
è che i margini di errore perché questo
qua ti arriva subito ei arriva subito è
un casino
vai vai non c'e neanche c'è point questo
il casinò ragazzi sera alle costole cioè
alle costole c'è la lisca la lisca cielo
alla lista porca vacca solo dietro il
tizio gira gira bravo bravo bravo però a
deviare il finale prima torna grazia
cielo ho fatto fatto ho fatto questa è
buona
questa buona soca colò non si può
buttare giù perché è stupido occhio
occhio non prendere quelle rocce proprio
quelle non devi prendere brava mamma mia
veramente mi sono saltati i nervi in
questo livello è stato orribile f lo dai
a tua sorella butta eccedete nel mare
dai ragazzi con colloqui per questi
episodi di io sono pesce perché nel
prossimo continueremo veramente
difficile ma fighissimo doug simulator
era da un po che non facevo una roba non
senza questo è un mix tra io sono pane
gozzi you later tutto mixato e legato
con i miei neuroni quindi un casino
bravi siamo 100 ragazzi di chat e mi
piace siete a creare sia stata
campanellina ero ci vediamo come sempre
anno prossimo video della ragazza
[Musica]
no